the easiest way to change behavior is to
get around other people who already have
the behavior you want normalized I would
always joke with my trainer like is your
six-pack contagious can it rub off on me
and I remember one day he was like yes
I'm like can we explain how that works
he's like because if you hung out with
me all the time I don't drink I'm up
early I work out every day I work out
really hard if you saw my intensity
level paired with the normal person's
intensity level AKA yours at the gym you
would probably up yours and it would
just be natural it's actually why I
think group fitness is so important a
lot of women we didn't have that
intensity and trained in US you didn't
find women fighting and wrestling with
kids that wasn't normalized and so when
it comes to really intense workout
Sports I tend to think women are better
off doing group classes because you see
a bunch of other competitive people
right next to you and you can up level
whereas my husband and maybe you if he's
in the gym he's just an animal nobody
could be in there for weeks and he would
act that way that's why I believe get
around other people who what you want
just is their Tuesday